gráfica encontrando las raíces y el
vértice de la parábola y es igual a
equis cuadrada 4 x 2 y bueno lo primero
que nos piden es el control de raíces
pero cuando las personas hablan de
encontrar las raíces a lo que están
refiriendo es encontrar los puntos en
donde mi parábola intersecta al eje de
las x y bueno cuando una función
intersecta al eje de las x lo que
estamos haciendo es tomar allí igual a 0
para encontrar dónde intercepta mi
parábola al eje de las x hay que hacer
que igual a 0 y entonces me queda x
cuadrada 4x menos 12 igual a 0 y bueno
esta es una ecuación cuadrática y si te
das cuenta tenemos un coeficiente de 1
al lado de la x cuadrada y por lo tanto
podemos factorizar esta expresión de una
manera sencilla estoy buscando dos
números que sumados me den cuatro y que
multiplicados me den menos 12 y esos
números son el 6 y el 2 el 6 y el -2 el
6 y el menos 2 funcionan es decir esto
lo puedo factorizar como x + 6 que a su
vez multiplica
2 esta es la factorización de x cuadrada
4 x 2 cm y esto a su vez es igual a 0
y bueno si tengo dos cosas multiplicadas
iguales a cero entonces o la primera es
cero en la segunda es cero y si x6 es
igual a cero entonces si restó seis de
ambos lados de la ecuación me queda que
x es igual a menos 6 mientras que de
este otro lado si sumo 2 de ambos lados
de la ecuación me queda que x es igual a
2 y ya con esto tengo los valores de x
en donde mi parábola intersecta al eje
de las x es decir mis raíces de esta
ecuación cuadrática que era justo lo que
quería y bueno entonces voy a poner 1 2
3 4 5 6 aquí es el menos 60 y bueno aquí
es el primer punto en donde esta
parábola intersecta el eje de las x
mientras que por otro lado tengo x
igualados esta es mi segunda raíz y es
también el punto en donde interceptamos
al eje de las x justo aquí en el 20 va a
pasar por ahí mi parábola y además
intersecta al eje de las x y después me
pide encontrar el vértice de esta
parábola y para
contra el vértice de esta parábola lo
que tengo que hacer explicarme en el
punto medio de estos dos y hay varias
formas de hacerlo sin embargo para mí
esta es la forma más fácil de encontrar
el vértice de una parábola dado que ya
tenemos la intercepta el eje de las x lo
que voy a buscar su eje de simetría y su
eje de simetría pasa por el punto medio
de estos dos y más aún el valor de x del
punto medio de estos dos es el valor del
vértice de mi parábola que estoy
buscando así que vamos a caer el punto
medio en x entre menos 6 y 2 y me queda
menos 6 + 2 entre 2 lo cual me da menos
2 y ahora hay que sacar el valor de bien
y para eso lo que voy a hacer es
sustituir el valor de x igual a menos 2
en mi función y me va a quedar que es
igual a menos 2 al cuadrado lo cual me
da 4 positivo 4 x menos 2 lo cual me da
menos 8 menos 12 y esto a cuánto es
igual
4 - 8 me da menos 4 - 4 - 12 me da menos
16 perfecto ya tengo el vez se me
parábola albertsen parábola está en el
punto menos 2
16 y es más vamos a graficar lo aquí
tenemos al vértice y entonces déjenme
poner todos los puntos necesarios para
llegar hasta el menos 16 menos siete
menos 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 menos 15 y 16
quedamos bastante abajo de lo que
teníamos en nuestro plano cartesiano sin
embargo no te preocupes aquí tengo el
betis siempre es más déjenme ponerlo por
aquí porque creo que no me quedo parejo
y aquí voy a tener yo al verde sem y
entonces éste sigue siendo mi ejes leyes
y este es el punto menos 2 menos 16 el
cual es el punto mínimo de mi parábola
por lo tanto voy a intentar hacer una
gráfica de esta parábola más o menos
y aquí está la gráfica de esta parábola
una vez que ya tengo el vértice y además
los puntos de intersección con el eje de
las x que por cierto además también sé
que mi eje de simetría es justo este que
estoy pintando ahorita es decir donde x
vale menos 2 y bueno también estoy
pensando en que había otras formas de
encontrar el vértice otra forma de
encontrar el valor de x es aplicando la
fórmula que hace tiempo habíamos
encontrado en donde decíamos que el
valor de x del vértice es igual a menos
de entre 2 am pero b vale 4 por lo tanto
me quedaría menos 4 entre menos 2 por 1
lo cual me da 2 y entonces menos 4 entre
2 nos dan menos 2 y otra vez obtengo el
mismo valor y bueno de hecho también hay
una tercera forma de encontrar el
vértice de esta parábola 10 fijándome en
esta expresión y completando el binomio
al cuadrado perfecto es decir me queda
que es igual a equis cuadrada más 4x y
voy a poner hasta acá en menos 12 y
ahora voy a completar el binomio el
cuadrado perfecto de esta expresión que
tengo aquí x cuadrada más 4 x más que es
un viendo en el cuadrado perfecto y
bueno para que se unan a guardado
hay que sumarle 4 pero a su vez también
hay que restarle 4 para que se mantenga
la igualdad y toda esta expresión que
tengo de amarillo es lo mismo que poner
x2 elevado al cuadrado date cuenta que
esto es x cuadrada más 4 x + 4 por lo
tanto lo que estoy haciendo es
completando el vídeo en el cuadrado
perfecto y del otro lado me queda menos
cuatro menos 12 lo cual es menos 16 y
bueno aquí tengo una expresión
equivalente a la misma función con la
que empecé pero aquí hay una gran
diferencia y quiero que te des cuenta en
esto x2 siempre va a ser mayor o igual
que 0 y por lo tanto el valor más
pequeño que puede tomar esta función es
cuando esta expresión x más 2 elevado al
cuadrado es cero porque es cero menos 16
me quedaría igual a menos 16 porque
cualquier otro valor que me salga x más
2 elevado al cuadrado nos va a dar algo
positivo y entonces cuando yo le reste
16 me va a salir algo más grande que
menos 16 por lo tanto cuando el que vale
menos 16 es decir aquí en el vez se me
parábola es donde yo tengo el punto
mínimo y entonces esto pasa cuando x + 2
tiene que ser igual a 0 lo que estoy
haciendo es esta parte igual a cero y
entonces
dejando x me queda que x es igual a
menos 2 y qué creés encuentra otra vez
el bet stein parábola y estas tres
formas son formas equivalentes de llegar
al mismo resultado